the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
[Music]
winning winning winning
oh
by david jones is his running mate the
most liberal senator in america
kamala
senator kamala harris
democrat kamala
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer their common fear
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you for
coming for you
if you are under the age senator
[Music]
i want to just first of all say i'm so
excited to be here
thank you thank you thank you there is
so much about what comes out of donald
trump's mouth
don't be rude to distract the american
people
from what he is doing every day that is
about neglect
negligence and harmony you are fake news
don't be rude and in the midst of this
public health pandemic
we have a donald trump
he knew the deal about coven he had been
informed
that it can kill people that it is five
times
as likely to kill as the flu he knew it
was airborne
he knew it could harm children
[Music]
kamala senator
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer they're coming
for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we have a
whoa hold on a second some suppression
balls starting there we have a very
important announcement coming from
president-elect joe biden today he's
going to be making some remarks about
health care
um and and maybe even laying out
the trajectory of um i mean in the
you know realistically the results in
the senate runoffs will determine
what biden is able to do about
healthcare once he's president
but at least in the context of
coronavirus remember that yesterday a
very triggering day
for president donald trump because joe
biden
launched his own coronavirus coronavirus
task force not a single one of joe
biden's family members is on the task
force that was weird for donald trump
but immediately filled it with doctors
and
it made sense who was on it and biden's
just moving forward now meanwhile donald
trump still has not accepted the
election results
mike pence is going on vacation mike
pompeo said there's going to be a smooth
transition to a second trump term
kaylee morgan annie gave a delusional
press briefing yesterday that was so
crazy
that even fox news had to cut away and
say we can't show you this stuff because
it's all
unproven allegations and we're going to
go through
all of it with you all of it with you
today today
excuse me and um
at the top of the hour is when joe biden
is scheduled now we have we're
monitoring
you know i always monitor feeds for you
guys we have an nbc
feed and a cbs feed i've been looking
for the feed
from joe biden himself and i've not
been able to find it even on the joe
biden channel
um yeah i'm not
i'm not seeing it past live streams
anyway
if anybody's aware of other streams in
other words
additional streams other than nbc and
cbs
um i would love to see it so that's
going on
let me go i want to make an effort
not to fall behind oh people ask me if
i'm five five come on guys i'm five
eight give me a break a five five oh no
i'm not five five
um i wanna try not to fall behind on
super chat so let me get to some of them
chaka seki says david how long before
the entire
trump train human griftifeed falls apart
i heard
kimberly gargoyle foil even offered lap
dances for campaign funds
i don't know that that's real news that
may be fake
nicholas silva says dave oh hold on
somebody's telling me to check the
videos tab here
uh so i go wait a second
joe biden videos
um no this is one day ago i don't see
anything scheduled for today
yeah so that that doesn't seem to be
working unfortunately
uh okay but if there's if there's other
ideas let me know
nicholas says um david i can't wait for
you and voosh two of my favorite
children of the lie beta
yeah um the youtuber who i guess someone
said is named ian i don't know if that's
true
um oh my god we already have to start
banning people
holy [ __ ] it's gonna be a long day guys
if we're already banning people
um
no i'm not autistic people asking if i'm
autistic i'm not
um yeah the youtuber known as
the ausch is going to be joining me
tomorrow and i expect it to be a really
interesting conversation
geshmake just signed up for a year david
your content is too good to consume for
free
mazel tov on the exponential growth of
subscribers and viewers
the growth has not been exponential i
want to be clear i don't want to be like
trump who doesn't understand exponential
let's not be like them okay the growth
has been
uh accelerating but not exponential okay
let's be clear
alex is looking forward to your chat
with vosh
steven says imagine a super spreader
event at a victory party for an election
night
you lost which you lost because you
didn't take covet seriously
that's what we're dealing with nick says
if you only count the legal votes kanye
wins
pompeo said there would be a smooth
transition into trump's second term
yeah so let's go let me just start i
always come prepared let's start a very
strong report from caitlin collins at
cnn
reporter is the state department
preparing to engage with the biden
transition team and if not
at what point does a delay hamper a
smooth transition or pose a risk to
national security
secretary pompeo there will be a smooth
transition
to a second trump administration let me
see if we can get video of that
pompeo smooth transition
let's see if that's on video oh here it
is currently preparing to engage with
the biden transition team
and if not at what point does a delay
hamper a smooth transition
or pose a risk to national security
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
right is the state department so i mean
look at the look on this clown's face
do you think he knows that trump is done
and he just kind of smirks because he
has to say this
um or do you think that
he really believes that trump is getting
another term
i really don't know i really don't know
all right so let's see someone said type
joe biden whoops i misspelled it
joe biden and then start scrolling down
and i will see the scheduled event oh
we've got a fox news feed okay good so
at least we've got i feel better having
three feeds for you guys
uh depending on only one feed
that's gone wrong many many times oh and
here's the joe biden one
perfect beautiful four feeds ready for
you guys
so that's mike pompeo um
we also have video we covered this press
conference yesterday
and when when kaylee mckennony started
telling lies which was basically when
she started speaking neil cavuto
actually had to bail take a listen to
this hold on let me actually turn this
up a bit
and here we go illegal vote well well i
just think we have to be very clear that
she's charging uh the other side is
welcoming fraud and welcoming illegal
voting unless she has more details to
back that up
i can't in good countenance continue
showing you this i want to make it he
can't
in good countenance continue showing it
to you sure that maybe they do have
something to back that up
but that's an explosive charge to megan
the other side is effectively
rigging and cheating uh if she does
bring proof of that of course we'll take
you back
so far she has started saying right at
the outset welcoming fraud welcoming
illegal voting
not so fast a little more after this
yeah so even neil it's like i'm not
praising fox news it's just
it was too crazy even for neil cavuto
uh which is you know it's ridiculous
but oh oh and by the way this so
infuriated trump that he was relegated
yesterday
to tweeting clips of newsmax not even
oan but newsmax check this out let me go
back a little bit
this is the stuff trump had to tweet
because even fox news is like listen
she's making stuff up out of thin air
look at the embarrassment of what trump
was tweeting those that are now coming
back to haunt us
ballots that were mailed out of state
people saying i haven't lived in
nevada for years we saw more than 3 000
people who uh lived out of state get
ballots we've
we've brought those to the authorities
uh attention
many they've brought ballots to
authorities this oh
this is jody heiss in i covered jodie
heist in 2014
jody heiss said women should really need
to get permission from husbands
to enter politics he is here as uh
someone very strongly making the case
that it was stolen from trump
it's very close and quite frankly i
believe it's on the verge of getting a
lot
closer right county just came out uh
just within the last hour or so
recognizing that they have a significant
issue
on reporting that they did on friday
uh wxia the nbc television affiliate
is already saying that this is
significantly going to
change the count in favor of president
trump
at the same time gwinnett county has
come out
anyway so this is the stuff trump was
tweeting here's another one
newsmax and oan they look like porn
parodies of fox news it's like very low
rent fox news where it actually could be
a it could be a joke it could be satire
or a porn parody take a listen
what can we expect to see in court right
we will pursue every legal avenue
because what's going on right now
is a total travesty this is not it's
like they
they can't even fully secure the trump
flag to the wall it just
it looks like crap united states of
america where we have
free and fair elections with legal votes
cast and that's what who decides
elections not media organizations
not the same people who said brett
kavanaugh would never sit on the supreme
court well what happened michael
avenatti went to jail
i mean if the media got to decide
anything there would have been collusion
uh president trump wouldn't even be the
president it also sounds like there's
plates like it sounds like someone's
having tea in the background
right because they've gotten everything
wrong they've been trying to overturn
our election results from 2016 for four
years now
and now this clear anyway i've seen isis
broadcasts with higher production value
and yes i did just steal that line
uh from the chat so that is that's been
trump's twitter let's see an hour ago
pennsylvania party leadership votes are
this week i hope they pick very tough
smart fighters and we will win
um tweeting marine corps propaganda
highly respected ken starr that's a bit
of a that's a bit of an oxymoron
pennsylvania's three-day extension of
the mail-in ballot deadline is a
constitutional travesty
ballot counting abuse this claim about
election fraud is disputed
watch for massive ballot counting abuse
and just like the early vaccine remember
i told you so
this claim about election fraud is
disputed we will win
that one's not flagged we are making big
progress
by the way why has caps locked been
engaged since last tuesday
really really strange um okay so that's
that if you're just joining us we're
standing by for statements from joe
biden about health care
i don't know if this will be related to
health care policy or if it will be
specifically related to the coronavirus
but i'm looking forward to it
i'm looking forward to complete
sentences and all of it
um so that is all extremely extremely
exciting i do want to say thanks to some
new members oh this is exciting lauren
kaplan
chinmay gupta erica mcclure
carolyn truffleman eula gratkop
tessa bayer natalie berkley
hold on joe mard sabri shayna pizarro
and julie davis have all signed up
at joinpakman.com wow and that puts us
at uh 10 new members and we are also
counting twitch and where are we on
twitch
one two three four five six
okay uh and six on twitch puts us at 16.
very much appreciate that
very much appreciate that um do i think
biden's inauguration crowd size will be
bigger than obama's in 2009
absolutely no idea no idea whatsoever
check out legal eagle new video he
covers all the lawsuits that's a good
idea
i do want to take a look at that legal
eagle powerful channel very very strong
channel
um oh uh
i do have a new song from jethro bradley
um yeah let's go let's go to the new
song from jethro
so jethro bradley is the
composer of such david pakman show
classics as
suppression balls song for kamala
paula white is winning this is an urgent
new track
jethro just sent this to me as i was
about to go on air
and it is wild now let me set this one
up for you i got a call the other day
from a disgusting trump sycophant who
was making no sense
and jethro turned that into
this track called highly triggered
individual okay let's take a listen to
it together
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to this i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
a little prickly now that your uh your
hero is there are you going to sit there
in your little kimono
and wear your little hat right
because the high-pitched kid voices in
the background are genius
called no free speech red chinese
communist
speech but you can't have pork because
you might offend the ayatollahs
after all you're going to love this too
no pork bomb and i hope they drop it
right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork but you can't
have pork right
but you can't have pork you like to
stick that microphone right up your ass
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
this is highly triggered extremely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
triggered
[Music]
[Music]
this has to be honored at the kennedy
center right i mean this just has to be
[Music]
end up done and trump's gonna stay in
there
wow
you're a real queer
anyway so this is a little peek behind
the curtain
that is that is just fantastic i mean
that that is
power um what is what a song that is
really a jam
um weird al yankovic is desperate for
the rights to it
um to do it as a serious song normally
weird al yankovic
does song parodies weird al was so
impressed with that
he wants the rights to turn that into a
normal song like a non-satire
it's crazy what's going on attorneys are
negotiating
uh the terms of that right now okay so
anyway
that's that's wild stuff and then um
oh people want to hear yeah i mean we
can do it we i played this in the
opening but
the other recent track is paula white is
winning which is a i i think this is a
great track too
the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory right
hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
anyway so the top uh the top djs are
really vying for
who's going to be able to do a collab on
those um very very exciting stuff
um and then just to get the i want to
get back to super chats and all of this
other stuff
but just to get one more thing out of
the way those of you who follow me on
instagram and you should because you see
pictures like this
on instagram um would be aware that we
got
three really really strong
um retweets on
twitter and i posted these to instagram
really really strong stuff
okay absolute superstar actress
gabrielle union
retweeting very strongly
very very strongly okay we also got
a retweet from the great leslie ann
brant of uh lucifer fame
as you can see she was so impressed
with my tweet that um
she had to take a picture even with the
tweet which is just another level
completely
and then for fans of the great show
mad men colin hanks also
with uh a very very strong
retweet so we had we we had us
really some strong tweets and you would
know about all of these
naturally if you were following me on
instagram
at david.pacman and i invite you to do
so i invite you to do so one of my
favorite memes also there as well
election related
[Applause]
absolutely astonishing now here come
what then
thoristieri
here's hogg
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh man that's really good stuff okay so
we got that we're i'm just going through
stuff i always have an agenda for you
guys
and want to make sure we get to all of
it so we've gotten to a lot of it so far
thank you very much
okay um other oh hold on let me see
twitch messages that are coming in
david glad i could support you for so
long uh keep up the good work that's
g-money writer
also hearing from who else am i hearing
from i guess that's it
that's it as far as uh twitch goes
super chat's coming in project says most
of my family was promoting trump because
he's anti-abortion
had an aunt call crying after he lost
they didn't like trump before
but wanted him to win this time should
we fear
latinos becoming republicans due to
religious reasons
that's actually an issue i'm going to be
addressing probably this week
but that is an important i mean i i have
a 15 minute segment from today
about this issue of of trumpists
and people moving i mean 71 million
people voted for the guy so we can make
fun of them
and some of them are dumb and some of
them are ignorant but unless you
seriously engage
with some strategy to bring these folks
over to our side
then um it's going to continue being
these razor type margins
and uh we're going to talk about that
ben
says possible theory trump's team
planned for this
has barr investigating to find voter
fraud the trump minions
framed to get trump reelected i just
don't think trump's that organized to be
perfectly frank
ritualistic mystic says i left you a
voicemail regarding an issue i'm facing
with trump supporters how often do you
check voicemails
we check voicemails daily we get 100
voicemails a day and we use one a day
and they almost always are under 70
seconds in length so like if you left
a three minute voicemail it will almost
certainly
not be played um and there's it's really
like a one in 100
shot because we do get a lot of
voicemails right now the trick to
getting a voicemail on the show
is you keep it pithy um
you get right to the point and
you you talk about something that has
been on the show like sometimes people
will call about something really obscure
and you know it's not it's not gonna
work for us basically
um do i have any voicemails
nah i don't want to get into other
voicemails right now
um yeah not right now okay
uh and then just keeping an eye on a few
other things
vinthur says the greatest evidence of
massive voter fraud so far
is trump telling his base to vote twice
yet very well said
very well said um
dmacc says what's your stance on
limiting senate terms like mcconnell is
on his seventh term
i would be in favor of limiting senate
terms i would
uh let's see i'm told biden may be live
ah here we go beautiful
okay good let's make sure we are in hd
we want appropriate volume for everybody
and all of that stuff
oh um we're going to oh will steve and
destiny bennell be up be back on the
show i'm glad to have him on the show
anytime yeah
uh i'm going to have a story about this
tomorrow
we have been 100 demonetized on facebook
it's so funny because yesterday i was
saying the reason we talk about
membership is sometimes we get
demonetized on youtube sometimes
facebook we have no control
uh we covered the um bannon beheading
fouchy story and as a result of covering
that
we are i'm not i'm not saying 98
demonetized i'm not saying 99
demonetized
yesterday we made xero on facebook
the day before we made 28 cents on
facebook we are
100 demonetized on facebook there's no
recourse
there's no buddy to contact there's
nothing
um and that's that's revenue we count on
so when i say hey you know if you like
what we do go to joinpakman.com grab a
membership
because sometimes these things happen
all we can control is the revenue
on our website it's not any theoretical
thing right we had adpocalypse on
youtube two years ago
now we're 100 demonetized on facebook
it's a mess
it's a mess so um in any case
i would love it if you went to
joinpakman.com we've got a new coupon
code fresh start
it's a perfect coupon code 70
off insane um our production team
actually tried to stage an intervention
with me today
saying you've got to stop these
discounts
need the you know our livelihood depends
on charging full price
and i said no we will not charge full
price we will do the discounts
um and we are also by the way we are
also counting
uh twitch subs but i won't mention it
again
the coupon code is fresh start you can
sign up at
joinpackman.com that's the place to do
it
okay other um super chats coming in
random great stuff is asking about
thoughts on daca under biden i'm a
dreamer and was relieved i can continue
to work and live here here which i
consider my country
we've been told that joe biden is
including restarting
the um dreamer what happened to my hair
restarting the dreamer program on day
one with an executive order
uh i i am confident that joe biden is
going to
deal with daca to the extent that he can
and um controlling the senate is a big
factor which is why we're going to be
focused so heavily
until january 5th on those two runoffs
in georgia
okay matt asking will the supreme court
or republican electors steal the
election
i believe they will not i am i am still
in the mindset that they will not
tim asking do i know if other leftists
are also demonetized i don't know
i really have no idea um it's
i it's very very hard to know what's
going on not that i've heard
um but i think somebody may have gone to
mark zuckerberg and said sir
demonetize parkman do i think biden will
legalize marijuana no he he can't it's
not within his purview to do so
um we're seeing more and more states
legalize and decriminalize
and i believe we will continue to see
that we could look at
the dea rescheduling cannabis but it is
not something biden can just
do so i don't expect to see that
because i don't think it's possible i
don't think it's possible from the
lawyers that
i've spoken to on that issue
um i am seeing people in the chat
talk about how most republicans
believe the election was stolen yeah we
actually talk about this on today's
bonus show producer pat and i talk about
it
um i try not to do the same content
twice in a day so if you want to hear a
discussion about
the level of support that this narrative
of a stolen election has
on the republican right check out
today's bonus show which you can get by
being a member
jonathan asking david any info on the
dominion voting machine fraud that
right-wingers keep talking about
nothing that a court has found um
compelling at this point in time
is the way i would say it courts so far
don't believe anything compelling has
been identified
let me say a few other thank yous we've
just brought in
14 additional website members which puts
us at 30
and because twitch counts we have an
additional
10 on twitch just making notes so i
don't
forget where i leave off beautiful
uh ashwaria chandrashekhar
chandra shakkar geez i i apologize in
advance
love your work david my boyfriend and i
are huge fans thank you i really
apologize for butchering your name let
me do it one more time
aishwarya chandrashikar
maybe maybe i don't know
justin says david would you be feasible
for you guys to try and organize
campaigning efforts to boost our chances
in the georgia runoffs
yeah i'm going to be regularly covering
really starting tomorrow
uh what's going on in those races
and um how you can donate how you can
phone bank etc
very important high percentage of our
activism time over the next
several weeks needs to be focused on
that
prior guy says it was a perfect call and
a perfect coupon code
jimmy says david trump knows he lost
it's all a smoke screen
to save face doesn't care if people get
harmed in the street believing his lies
overt narcissist yeah that's a view i
i'm getting emails from people with both
views the view that trump knows he lost
and this is to save face
and the view that trump really is being
kept sheltered and
people are telling him you've got this
you've got this keep fighting keep
fighting i don't know what the truth is
um
joe says david even if georgia wins two
senate seats does that mean it's 50 50
if so who's the leader well
uh if it's 50 50 the vice president is
the tie-breaking vote that's kamala
harris
um and i'm kidding it's kamala i know
but i'm just i have to actually i
shouldn't even joke about the trump
pronunciation
kamala harris and kamala harris gets
kamal harris gets to pick the senate
majority leader as well
so that's a good situation for us kmag
says can i get a happy birthday biden is
my present
yes happy birthday to kmag
collins destiny's very interested in
trying to turn a district in georgia
runoffs
if you haven't talked to him about it
yet okay i have not talked to him about
it yet
and uh pedro says kavanaugh likely to
let the affordable care act stand based
on his comments
let's wait and see kavanaugh's slippery
kavanaugh's a slippery guy can you guys
imagine by the way
how triggering it will be to the right
for kamala harris to not only be vice
president but
if there's if we if we were to get these
two seats in the georgia runoff and
kamala harris gets to be the
tie-breaking vote
on every single senate bill that is
otherwise going down party lines
these right-wingers are going to explode
they are not going to know
what to do with themselves and i look
forward to it to be perfectly frank
donna says skipping my super chat again
oh well
you know i'm doing the best i can donna
says
people saying the media doesn't call
elections don't understand that they're
going by the numbers
well people saying the media doesn't
call elections seem to misunderstand
that there's it's not unique to this
year that the election isn't certified
until electors vote on december 14th
that's always the case
there's nothing new media outlets are
always
doing math and looking at the returns
and deciding
who is this still contested or is it
over
it's not special every year that's the
case
it's just this year republicans are
talking about it they're pathetic
but but listen a parallel presidency is
starting and it's starting right now
uh joe biden meeting with the
coronavirus task force yesterday that he
created
joe biden with remarks on health care
today he's not waiting and i think it's
exactly right
luis says any way i can get on discord
and talk about the impact biden may be
passing immigration reform and why i
think polls were off
uh we we may yeah i mean we're going to
be taking we're opening discord tomorrow
to record some calls for the friday show
i don't think i'm opening phone lines
today
but we'll see how long this goes but
that's something i would be glad to talk
about paul says watching from scotland
trump is making your country look like a
third-rate tin pot autocracy
severing accountability and power from
the
electorate well said well said
tristan says feels like there won't be a
transition what are your thoughts
listen i don't care you know
i don't care it's does trump leave
michael cohen said that he believes
trump may leave for
um christmas vacation and just never
return to dc that's fine i'm hearing
trump may never welcome joe biden to the
white house just go
i'm hearing trump may not go to the
inauguration
great we've just got to get him out i
don't care
the only concern is can they actually
hamper the biden transition in terms of
getting things in place
it appears as though they can try but it
is unlikely that they will be able to do
it so i'm not i'm really not hugely
worried about it
inauguration is january 20th exactly who
cares
just go get out don't let the door hit
you on the way out
frozen over studio says i've been
hearing oh wait where did that go
i've been hearing rumors that this
division of the country could spark
another civil war
no i know that there are some youtubers
who make hyperbolic headlines about
civil war and you know stuff like that
some of them also said trump would win
in a landslide from what i've read
you know i think protests are certainly
possible
i don't believe there is going to be a
civil war
and you know part of the thing that a
lot of these right-wingers don't
understand
is if there were civil war and the
country was split roughly among
partis along partisan lines now if a
state
has a republican governor but is very
blue
like massachusetts which side is it on i
think it's abundantly clear
massachusetts is on
the blue side um a state like arizona
with a lunatic
weaponized fiasco republican governor
doug ducey
but they voted for biden which like
arizona is a difficult one okay but
anyway the point is
if you sort of split the country that
way
the red country that's left over is
completely financially unsustainable
they talk about welfare and all this
stuff the blue states
are the welfare supporters
of the red state takers just look it up
look at how much money
states pay in to the federal government
versus how much states pay out
the red country that a lot of these
people want would be
completely unsustainable financially
just completely unsustainable
that's a story for another day um
okay will pence pardon trump before noon
on january 20th i don't know that that's
that's coming up a lot
um i have no idea
rika asking if i'm worried about
violence i have military friends told to
pack a bag and be ready to go to philly
i do have concerns about violence yeah i
do
send comst asking whether i think
there's a risk trump will commit an
expanded nuclear suicide
i do not think so no i don't i don't
think so
let me say thank you to the 20 new
website members who just signed up at
joinpakman.com
putting us at 60. a lot of round numbers
today
and another six twitch subs i love
which puts us at 66. now what hold on a
second we're let me
we're trying to get to 100 and we're at
66.
what percentage is that six divided by
ten is six
okay but you got to do a point point six
carry the zero drive drop down thinking
back to my uh early elementary math six
per minute oh
66 percent of the way there okay that's
good
boom unbelievable
uh okay there's people who think that's
for real that's the saddest part
oh this is kind of interesting if this
person is watching i don't want to um
i think it's funny i'm not call i think
it's great that you were concerned but
i got an email the other day where
someone wrote to me
and they s they basically they were
trying to do an intervention
they said you know david i've been
watching your streams this is real
i'm not this is not a bit they said
david i've been watching your streams
i think you may be drinking a little too
much you're an adult
you obviously can do whatever you want
this is not a joke
okay but i think that
maybe you're having an issue with
drinking
which is so funny because i've never
been a big drinker but especially since
the pandemic
because i'm doing so little i i've
barely had
any alcohol and i wrote back and i said
i appreciate the concern i'm not
drinking
like at all i really don't drink but can
you tell me what are the symptoms you
saw that suggested to you that i was
having a drinking problem and i didn't
hear back from them i would love to know
and maybe it's something innocuous like
maybe the lights make my eyes
shiny i i really don't know but it was
really really interesting
obviously i'm in huge denial guys i'm
just i can't even accept that i have a
problem yeah
okay other super chats coming in
can trump coup against biden no i don't
think so
captain says um oh wait hold on these
are coming in quickly
i'm having trouble catching up let me
actually get away from super chats just
briefly
um because i want to just reset where
where we are we are 17 minutes late to a
joe biden
event where he is going to make a major
announcement about healthcare
now a lot of people wrote to me saying
they think the healthcare
announcement is going to be about um
[Music]
the policy he hopes to pass i actually
think that would be a little premature i
i'm thinking this is more likely related
to coronavirus
but we'll see we'll see he had his
coronavirus task force meeting yesterday
i think it's more likely that today
um is about something related to
coronavirus but i don't know
and we will we will simply have to wait
and see
the latest numbers continue to be pretty
ugly
today we are already at 60 000 new cases
it's only 2 pm on the east coast
and 609 deaths yesterday 125
000 cases being a monday we did have a
lower death number
as many of you know there's this kind of
weekly cycle where on monday
uh after the weekend death numbers tend
to be lower but the numbers in general
are are not looking great as you can see
remember when we thought
this was the peak and we went from
32 000 new a day down to like 20
and then we spiked to 70 000 and then
some people thought
this is the peak and then we got down to
36
000 and look at where we are right now
over 100
000 cases every single day now for
a while deaths fortunately
not spiking as high as they might but as
you can see the seven day moving average
on deaths has been climbing for the last
three weeks and we're expecting it to
continue climbing
it's very very ugly and the latest
numbers are that we are getting very
close
by next week we will be at a quarter
million deaths officially
the real death number as many of you
know is probably fifty thousand
uh to a hundred thousand higher than
that if you look at excess mortality
depressing but we need leadership on
coronavirus
and hopefully we will get it from joe
biden because at this point
trump's done trump is absolutely done
with that um
brian is asking about my favorite frank
ocean song i'm not too familiar with
frank ocean
there's one song that keeps that spotify
regularly plays for me i don't remember
the name of it
but i uh i'm not too familiar with uh
frank ocean's discography
for lack of a better term other super
chats here that i want to get i can't
get to all of them but i will try to
get to some red states don't need to be
sustainable since they've got slavery to
go back to that's
that's pretty harsh alan says my only
hope is trump leaves the country after
all these years of myself being told
to leave the country if i didn't like it
yeah leaving the country is not as easy
as some might think
quite frankly mom fur babies
maltese says with a 50 super chat i am
so worried that they're going to reverse
the decision
i joined your channel and use the code
thank you
i do appreciate your show because i
think you were totally fair
i am so happy about biden harris win
thank you i appreciate that
laura says david could you speak on the
schumer warren student debt relief
proposal they are asking biden about
canceling the first 50k of student debt
yeah i saw the headline
i've not uh dug into the details yet and
um i am very very interested in looking
at that now
le i'm seeing some people in the chat i
don't know if these are trolls or not
but let me address it
talking about the coronavirus vaccine
will be mandatory
oh my god we've got to start banning
people again this is crazy
oh thanks mods very quickly on that i i
appreciate that ban hammer being dropped
here's the deal with mandatory vaccines
okay i want people to listen really
really closely i'm about to say
something about whether
the coronavirus vaccine will be
mandatory
make sure it's quiet around you if
you're wearing headphones listen very
closely okay
there will not be a government mandated
coronavirus vaccine
okay everybody heard that now um what
you may see
are airlines who say we're a private
company
we require a vaccination certificate if
you want to fly with us it's not the
government
if you don't have to fly with us if you
want to fly with us
you need a vaccination certificate you
might see public schools
or even private schools say
if you want your kid in this school
you need a vaccination certificate you
you very well may see that
you may see after the vaccine has been
around for a while
you may see doctors offices a
pediatrician's office for example that
says
we only accept this is not an emergency
room right there's no duty to treat here
we're a pediatrician's office we don't
accept
unvaccinated kids at this office i
already know pediatricians
in new york city who already had
policies
of we don't accept kids here without the
measles vaccine
if you want to bring your kid to our
office they've got to be vaccinated for
measles it's not the government
making the vaccine mandatory it's
a business saying we've calculated that
even though we might lose some business
by doing this
we want to for the greater good or
to protect our business or whatever our
customers need a vaccine
that is not mandatory vaccination you
could have
employers as people are pointing out
if i am uh you know imagine after after
covid we get back to an office
everybody's working together
i as an employer yes as an employer in
the state of massachusetts the
commonwealth as trump talks about
i could say listen uh my my policy
free market i'm a business i can do what
i want you know
within within the law um if you want to
work in my office you've got to have a
vaccination certificate
i just i i want vaccinated people around
me that's it
um so anyway you know
there's not going to be mandatory
vaccination by the government
but there are a lot and by let me just
go one step further
the fact that we all know
that 20 30 40 of the country doesn't
plan
to get the vaccine that's the problem
the problem is not imaginary vaccination
uh mandatory vaccination that's not
going to happen
the problem is with everything that's
going on
according to some polls 40 percent of
the of the country doesn't plan to get
the vaccine
let's focus on the problem my friends
um yeah in fact i plan to make the
vaccine mandatory
for twitch viewers and youtube viewers
not facebook viewers so the un my
unvaccinated audience will only be
allowed to watch the streams on facebook
that's something we're planning on on
putting in place all right thank you
let me say thank you to some other
members
61 that is 17
new members at joinpakman.com
puts us at 83 and on twitch
an additional three which puts us at 86.
that's fantastic that's absolutely
fantastic
uh 86 my friends delightful number
okay as we wait for joe biden just a
couple
did i see people asking whether i uh
showed the strong retweets yes i did i
can show them again
we had three really strong retweets on
twitter
we had one from a gabrielle union
hollywood superstar gabrielle union i
believe wife of dwyane wade right
is that true no
yes anybody know
yes okay good actress gabrielle union
very powerful endorsement okay um
for those who watch lucifer leslie ann
brant
strong retweet and she even
um added in a picture of herself
reacting to my tweet which is great
i printed these out and put them on my
fridge
they're really nice and then the great
colin hanks actor
son of tom hanks uh very very strong
and we love it we absolutely love it um
much like don jr said if it's in the
summer we love it
okay nobody knows who these people are
perfect
okay rocco thompson says david can you
assure us the presidential decision
won't be reversed i wasn't worried
before the anxiety among the general
populace is seeping in
i can't assure you of anything i mean i
really can't
i don't see any path to trump uh getting
a second term but i can't assure you of
anything
uh that's scary will biden rejoin the
iran deal uh we don't know yet hasn't
said but i hope so
we have a final sanitizing of the
president-elect's lectern and we're
expecting
uh joe biden very soon john milne says
what's your stance on the dispute
between justice stems and moderate dems
i have no idea i have not seen a word
about it i couldn't tell you
have i read about what biden wants to do
to reverse betsy devos if so how likely
is it to happen my wife is a teacher i
have not read about that yet
you know i tweeted yesterday that i i
don't think
joe biden will put jill biden
as secretary of education i don't think
joe biden
should put a family member in his
cabinet cabinet but that being said
jill biden would be a dramatically
better secretary of education
than betsy devos it's just it's the
irony of what's going on like
trump filled his staff with family
members and cronies
biden isn't going to do that he just so
happens to have better people in his
family
than some of the people that are
actually in donald trump's cabinet
it's it's stunning stunning
uh let's see have i seen the 2024
electoral college map re-census
no electoral college map
let's see projected map
based on new census oh i'm not finding
anything newer than last year about that
so i don't know that i think we just
need to wait for the census to finish
[Music]
based on july 1 2019
24 electoral yeah i uh i let let's wait
until that's finalized because i'm not
it's not clear to me whether i'm finding
anything that actually is based on
the real census response so let's let's
wait on that a little bit
inconsolable says i think you come off
as unfair on the vaccine issue sometimes
a large portion of the people who
wouldn't get the vaccine won't get it
because they intelligently don't trust
the government yeah no no no i i just
totally disagree
the the anti-vaxx issue is interesting
because
it brings together some on the left and
right
for different reasons you have left-wing
anti-vaxxers who don't trust
big pharma and right-wing anti-vaxxers
who don't trust
the government but the truth is that
uh vaccines are safe we have a process
the uh you know i understand saying
i'm uh i have a health situation that
precludes me from getting the vaccine i
i understand that
but a general distrust of government um
if you're saying that that's a valid
reason not to get a vaccine
i am not aware of anything empirical
that would support that
and uh until such time you know
that's that's my position rocco said oh
no i already got to rocco's question
hold on
have i heard of janis varufakis and can
i interview him we've reached out to him
at least once have not heard back
uh we'd love to have him on thoughts on
the system of a down comeback songs yeah
i heard one um
i heard i have like spotify in my car
now
and sometimes it'll say hey we have
david's daily mix
new fresh tracks and there was a new
system of a down song
it was okay it was okay
uh what else david do you think biden
will appoint obama to an official post
i would doubt it it's it's unusual that
that happens
um for anything official so i would be
surprised
languin says i would join but i'm
worried about too many direct
debits i don't even know what that means
anita recount nice says when do you
project the maga rallies to resume
there's an axios report that says it
will be very soon
here's kamala and joe let's take a
listen guys
good afternoon today the supreme court
heard arguments in a case
that could strike down the affordable
care act in its entirety
if the supreme court agrees with the
opponents of the act
their decision could take health care
away
from 20 million americans it could take
away protections for more than 100
million people
with pre-existing conditions in our
country and hurt the millions of
americans
who have come to rely on the affordable
care act
getting rid of the affordable care act
will take us backward
to a time when people could charge a
woman more for her health care
than they could charge a man simply
because she's a woman
to a time when pregnancy could be
considered a pre-existing condition
it will take away free birth control and
contraceptive coverage for women
this is all happening at a moment when
our country is suffering through a
pandemic
that has claimed more than 238
000 lives and we all know
that if the affordable care act is
struck down
communities of color would be hit
particularly
hard black asian hispanic and native
american
because they are at a greater risk of
pre-existing conditions from asthma
to diabetes to lupus and they are also
three times as likely to contract
covid19
and twice as likely to die as others
now i know we all know that we just had
an election
in america an election where health care
was very much
on the ballot our country had a clear
choice in this election each and every
vote
for joe biden was a statement
that health care in america should be a
right
and not a privilege right each and every
vote
for joe biden was a vote to protect
and expand the affordable care act
not to tear it away in the midst of a
global pandemic
and joe biden won the election
decisively
with more votes than have ever been cast
in american history
it amounts to 75 million
voices and counting calling on the
supreme court
to see this case for what it is
a blatant attempt to overturn
the will of the people and the
president-elect
and i cannot let that happen right
and now it is my honor to introduce
president-elect joe biden
this is the big man himself right oh
full masking there i like that
and a little interim re-sanitation of
the lectern
wow i mean these people are taking it's
almost like they're taking the virus
seriously guys wow
thank you uh good afternoon everyone
this morning as was stated united states
supreme court heard oral arguments
on the case of grave importance to the
american people
this case represents the latest attempt
by the far-right ideologues to do what
they've been repeatedly failed to do
for a long time in the courts in the
congress
and the court of public opinion over the
last decade to eliminate the entirety of
the affordable care act
twice already the supreme court has
upheld the landmark law
in 2012 and again in 2015
and the congress expressing the popular
will of the american people on a
bipartisan basis
has rejected numerous attempts numerous
efforts by president trump
to erase the law as well now in the
middle of a deadly pandemic
that has infected more than 10 million
americans
nearly one in every 32 americans
often with devastating consequences to
their health
these ideologues are once again trying
to strip
health coverage away from the american
people the goal
of the outgoing administration is clear
from the brief they filed in the supreme
court
it asserts and i quote the entire aca
thus must fall end of quote
now i'm not naive about the fact that
health care is an issue that has divided
americans in the past
but the truth is the american people are
more united on this issue today
than they are divided recently as last
month the leading survey found that
american people want to keep the
affordable care act in place
by an overwhelming margin of 58 to 36
percent
79 percent of the american people
including nine out of ten democrats
eight out of ten independents and two
thirds of republicans
want to keep the aca protections for
people with pre-existing conditions
which would be eliminated if this
lawsuit were to succeed
this doesn't need to be a partisan issue
it's a human issue it affects every
single american family
we can't subvert the growing consensus
the american people
based on an argument put forward in the
briefs seeking to invalidate the law
that even many conservative legal
scholars including in the national
review consider to be
quote ridiculous let's be absolutely
clear about what's at stake
the consequence of the trump
administration's argument are not
academic or an abstraction
academic imagine that they're a matter
of life and death in a literal sense
this argument will determine whether
health care coverage of more than 20
million americans who acquired and
earned the affordable care act
will be ripped away in the middle of the
nation's worst
pandemic in a century over 100 million
people as the vice president-elect
pointed out over 100 million people with
pre-existing conditions
like asthma diabetes cancer could once
again be denied coverage
whether complications from covet 19 like
lung scarring and heart damage will be
the next flood of pre-existing shouldn't
biden be insulting someone by now used
to jack up premiums
or deny coverage altogether for millions
of survivors
who have struggled won and fought
the co the coronavirus fought against
the loss of their life
this argument is going to determine
whether women as is pointed out
will once again be charged higher
premiums just because they're women
or seniors will see their prescription
drug costs
go up and like kids who
whether or not they can stay on their
parents plan solay's 26th
where their annual lifetime benefits
will be
reimposed so someone could walk in and
say
die in peace you run out of your
coverage
it's in hyperbole it's real as real as
it gets
when a family is faced with the awful
news of a child's diagnosis with
leukemia
or a mom forced to battle against breast
cancer
an accident that leaves loved ones
unable to live the life
they've always known it stops your heart
it stops your heart and wrenches
your entire world right off its axis
when that happens
and many of you know that from your own
personal experiences
believe me i know the feeling and too
many american families do as well
in that moment the very last thing on
your mind
the very last thing should be on your
mind is whether you can afford the
treatment
afford the affordable care act was
created to put a stop
to that inhumanity it was created to
ensure that families
thrust into their worst nightmare of
their lives could focus
not only not on money but on the fight
that really matters
obamacare is a law that every american
should be proud of
it's why people with pre-existing
conditions are protected in this country
it's a law that delivered vital coverage
as i said before for 20 million
americans
who did not have coverage it's a law
that reduced prescription drug price
costs
for nearly 12 million seniors
it's a law that saved lives and spared
countless families from financial ruin
so this effort to bypass
the will of the american people the
verdict of the courts in the past the
judgments of congress
in my view is simply cruel and
needlessly divisive
regardless of the outcome of this case i
promise you this
beginning on january 20th the vice
president-elect harris and i
we're going to do everything in our
power to ease the burden of health care
on you and your families
i promise you that as i said i will
protect your health care like i protect
like as with my own family
and we've been unfortunately significant
consumers of health care
that starts by building on the
affordable care act with the dramatic
expansion of health care coverage
and bold steps to lower health care
costs
my transition team will soon be starting
its work
to flesh out the details so that we can
hit the ground running
tackling costs increasing access this is
why the senate runoffs matter because
without the senate
most of this will be just his ideas and
that's just an
unfortunate reality we have to come to a
lot of these people around the country
as you've gone all over the world
all over the country enduring illnesses
faced with risky choices
losing their employer plans and droves
already 10 million have already lost
their employer plans
they need a lifeline and they need it
now
they should have to hold their breath
they shouldn't be in that position
waiting to see if the supreme court is
going to
wrench away the peace of mind
they've come to now rely on
so we're going to get right to work i
promise you
addressing the issues that families are
are talking about around the kitchen
tables this morning
making sure that they can get bed
tonight with the peace of mind that they
deserve
and fulfilling our moral obligation to
ensure that here in america healthcare
is a right for all
not a privilege for a few so come
january
we're going to work quickly with the
congress to dramatically ramp up
healthcare protections
get americans universal coverage lower
health care costs
as soon as humanly possible
that's the promise i make to you we're
going to fight
for your family's health coverage the
same way we fight for our own family's
health coverage
we want every single american to know if
you're sick
if you're struggling if you're worried
about how you're going to
get going to get through the day we will
not abandon you that is a promise
will not leave you to face these
challenges alone
we're going to get through this we're
going to get through it together
and we're going to build a healthcare
system that puts you and your families
first
and that every american can be proud of
i want to thank you
all for listening may god bless you may
god keep you safe in this coveted
environment
and may god protect our troops now i'm
told that we're going to have
you're going to take five questions
there about
questions here we go okay
thank you mr president-elect during the
campaign
you said you were not naive about how
difficult it would be to
unite the country oh this is good it's
now three days after
you were projected as the
president-elect the
president himself says he has won this
election his own administration has not
moved forward to give you access to what
you need to do to begin
the work of your transition just a few
minutes ago the secretary of state when
asked if he would
cooperate with a smooth transition he
said there will be a smooth transition
to a second
trump administration i wonder if you
have a message for
the president who may well be watching
right now what will he say here
do you expect to be able to work with
republicans when so many have thus far
refused to even acknowledge your victory
well first of all uh we are already
beginning
the transition we're well underway and
uh
the ability uh for uh the administration
in any way by failure to recognize us as
our
win uh does not uh change the dynamic at
all in what we're able to do
we've announced yesterday as you know
the health
group that we put together today we're
going to be going moving along
in a consistent manner
putting together our administration the
white house and
reviewing he's just gonna do it for the
cabinet physicians
and nothing's gonna stop that and uh
and so i'm confident that uh the fact
that they're not willing to acknowledge
we want at this point
is uh not of much consequence in our
planning and what we're able to do
between
basically we don't care january 20th we
don't care
secretary pompeo and i also
warned during the campaign that as the
walls closed in on the president he
would behave more erratically yesterday
he fired his defense secretary
on twitter are you worried that he's the
government tired of
what are you saying to the world leaders
who are calling you at this point about
the situation here
well first of all uh i'm letting him
know that america is back
uh we're going to be back in the game
it's not american alone
number one hired him on twitter
opportunity to speak uh now
six world leaders um and uh
and the response has been very uh
fulsome energetic and uh
they're all looking forward to being
able to from
from great britain to france to germany
to canada et cetera and ireland
so i i feel good about the ability to
i said when we announced that the next
president is going to
inherit a divided country and a world in
disarray
the reception and welcome we've gotten
around the world from our allies and our
friends has been real
i'm having a number of other calls to
return and
so i feel confident that we're going to
be able to uh
put the mayor put america back in the
place of respect that it had before
wow
mr president-elect senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell has suggested
today that he may not recognize
the outcome of this election until the
electoral college meets
next month have you spoken to your
longtime
friend in the senate mr mcconnell and
what do you make of his specific
comments over the last 24 hours
i haven't had a chance to speak to mitch
my expectation is that i will
do that not too distant future um that
should be interesting
the whole republican party has been put
in a position with
a few notable exceptions of uh um
being mildly intimidated by the
sitting president but there's only one
president at a time
he's president we're going to have the
electoral college we'll
be making their judgment in december
it'll be announced in early january
but in the meantime i hope to get a
chance to speak to mitch if i could
follow up without
transition funding will you be able to
go through with the proper
transition that's needed would you like
access to the pdb
and will you authorize legal action or
would that be too divisive do you
believe
i we can get through without
uh the the funding uh we're in a
position
that uh we feel very good about our
there's nothing that slows up our
efforts to put things together
obviously the pdb would be useful but
it's not necessary i'm not the sitting
president now
and so uh we don't see anything in
slowing us down quite frankly shouldn't
he be insulting people by now this is
weird
thank you mr president-elect and
congratulations to you both
have you tried to reach out at all to
the president and if he is watching
right now
what would you say to him mr president
look forward to speaking with you
you say that you are being able to move
ahead without interruption but
to jeff's point presumably at some point
you will need access to more classified
information
to secure facilities and the like what
options
are you considering how will you move
ahead if the president continues to
refuse
to concede well look uh
access to classified information is
uh is useful uh but
i'm not a position to make any decisions
on those issues and if he waits long
enough trump will just blab
classified info and he'll get everything
he needs to know until
january 20th it would be nice to have it
but it's not
critical and uh that's we're just going
to proceed the way we have we're going
to
we're going to do exactly what we'd be
doing if he had conceded
and said we've won which we have
uh and so there's nothing really
changing but not ruling out legal action
no i don't see a need for legal action
uh quite frankly
i think the legal action is uh you're
seeing it uh
play out the actions he's taking uh and
so far
there is no evidence of any of the
assertions made
by the president or secretary pompeo
[Laughter]
that laugh pompeo
thank you mr president-elect uh
democrats are on track to lose uh
a handful of seats in the house of
representatives um
that could make it harder to pass
legislation with just democratic votes
and i'm just curious how does that
impact your plans
perfect questions you think you can get
through this congress
especially if the senate uh remains in
gop control important question during
the lame duck will you be coordinating
with speaker pelosi
on how she should be negotiating with
republicans well i've spoken to the
leader
and i've spoken to the minority leader
in the house
and one of the urgent things that need
be done
is people need relief right now
right now small businesses people who
are about to be evicted from their homes
because they can't pay their mortgage
unemployment insurance you know what's
going to happen is you're going to see
what people don't realize is the failure
to provide state and local assistance
you're going to see police officers
firefighters first responders laid off
and i think the pressure is is going to
build but
the fact is that i would hope that the
president at least has
the
the sensitivity and knowledge you know
that a lot of people
sensitivity right now between now and
the time we get elected
until we get sworn in and so it's my
hope and expectation
i've i'm sure that the majority the
speaker of the house as well as the
minority leader are
working right now into the priorities
they have laid out
but do you plan to be active in those
negotiations working with speaker pelosi
to represent democrats on the table well
i
they we've been talking and they know my
views and
uh and i support what they're doing and
then my second question was about the
senate
do you plan to campaign in georgia
before your inauguration to help
democrats in the two runoff races there
as they try to flip the senate
and uh how important is a democratic
held senate to your agenda well
obviously it'd be much better if we had
uh a tie in the senate which means that
this vice president become incredibly
important beyond what she already is
but we're going to do anything we can
that they think we can do to help
and does the democratic senate help your
cabinet chances that does that
uh change how you consider who you
nominate i doubt
no i don't think so i uh i i take uh
mcconnell at his word i understand he
said that he will make it clear who he's
prepared to support and not support and
that's a negotiation
that i'm sure we'll have look one of the
things that
that i would do as uh as president
elect and when i become president is lay
out
to the republicans as well as the
democrats who we intend to
name for each cabinet joe's got to stay
on mike i hope we're able to be in a
position to let people know
at least a couple that we want before
thanksgiving and we'll just work this
out
look i am uh i am not
a pessimist as you know and i think
there are
enough republicans who've already spoken
out but i think there'll be many more
not many more there'll be a larger
number
once the uh the election is declared and
i'm sworn in
to be able to get things done i think
they understand for example i
can't imagine there not being a
willingness
on the part of republicans they're going
to be significant pressure to deal with
health care
their own constituencies are in that
position so i
i'm not i hope so i'm not sure about
this i think we can get a lot done
thank you sir what do you say to the
americans that are anxious over the fact
that president trump has yet
to concede and what that might mean for
the country well
um i just think it's an embarrassment
quite frankly the only thing that
how can i say this careful joe
i think it
will not help the president's legacy
i think well said i know from my
discussions with foreign leaders thus
far that
they are hopeful that the united states
democratic institutions are viewed once
again as being strong and endured
and uh but i think at the end of the day
uh
you know it's all going to come to
fruition on january 20th
and between now and then i hope an
expectation is that the american people
are
do know and do understand that there has
been a transition
even among republicans who
are people who voted for the president i
understand the sense of
loss i get that but i think
the majority of the people who voted for
the president a lot voted for him
a significantly smaller number but a lot
voted for him
i think they understand that we have to
come together i think they're ready to
unite and i believe we can pull the
country
out of this uh
um politics that we've seen for the last
uh
last five six seven years and just to
follow up on a previous question
how do you expect to work with
republicans if they won't even
acknowledge you as
president-elect they will
[Laughter]
thank you all so very much oh man
i i really don't know what to make of
this because he
seemed to be hesitant to insult anyone
and kind of like he would be asked a
question and then he would think about
the answer it was
really jarring from what we've been
experiencing i don't i don't really know
what to make of it but i guess we're
just going to
have to kind of get used to it right i
don't i don't think we have
much of a choice it's very very strange
but
we're working on it a little maybe
post-event sanitization
wouldn't be the worst thing in the world
there very interesting event guys
very very interesting event i want to
follow up on a conversation about
vaccines from before
inconsolable says clarifies about
vaccine
it's not general distrust of government
or pharma it's that this government has
suppressed and fired reputable
scientists
yeah so listen for people who want more
than just
trump saying the vaccine is safe i think
we've cleared
that hurdle because the vaccine is
from a german company manufactured by
pfizer
without any involvement in operation
warp speed
will be submitted for authorization in
multiple countries at the same time
so it's not a vaccine trump was involved
in they've made good on not submitting
for authorization
too soon we will see what other
countries health regulatory agencies
decide at the same time that we see what
the fda decides
so the point is i think we're going to
have much we're not going to be
depending on trump to tell us if it's
safe
we're going to have more than enough
information more than enough information
by that point in time
please make sure because we are going to
continue streaming the transition and
building up to the eventual inauguration
we'll be streaming georgia senate
debates if they happen
ossoff has challenged purdue we'll see
if he accepts he was eviscerated in that
last debate
we will be covering the election results
on january 5th
we're covering it all please follow
if you're watching on twitch please
subscribe
if you're watching on youtube this is
all free and please make sure to like
our page if you're watching
on facebook uh we are going to have
jethro bradley play us out
and i will be back with you guys very
very soon america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
they're coming here from africa
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
winning winning
[Music]